hi everyone I'm nature from Stanford I
talked about Island fantastic which is
drawing word for his greater Valiant who
is also from Stanford
so this word started from a 12 problem
written by Ian tulis computer miniature
that appeared in a competitive
programming contest called urotorjam1020
so the problem is as follows suppose we
have a couple of pens and a whole
different amounts of range as sponsor at
the end and these amounts are not known
to us
we want to put a pen that has a maximum
amount of ink and let's say the maximum
amount is 10 units of length
so what should we do
one natural thing to do is to test each
pen by writing with it so let's say we
test each pen for one unit of time and
see what happens
so once it might happen is that box of
hands become empty so we know we
shouldn't pick it
but still we have no idea about the
remaining amount of ink in each of the
other four pens let's pause the test
we also know that this testing already
reduced the amount of inch in the
maximum pan and it becomes nine units
instead of 10 units
even those four Pens have already passed
the test it's not ideal to paint wrong
depends randomly because it might be
that only one of the pens holds nine of
the ink but the other three pens just
barely positive test and don't have much
ink in it
we know that this problem
has two important ingredients one is
that we have to make a selection for
many choices and we are uncertain about
the quality of each option
also while we can obtain some
information about each option such
information is very sparse and obtaining
them has a very high cost in reducing
the value of each option
while the Fantastic example sounds like
a toy problem
such a model has also other character
motivations such as the hiring process
that we have a few candidates to choose
from and our interview or hiring process
will impact the potential of each
candidate
also we can see through examples that we
want to invest in one of the many
startups we don't know the value of
potential of growth in each company so
what we can do is to wait until a
certain amount of growth is obtained in
each company so let's say we wait until
the net worth doubles
so while this waiting increase our
confidence in that company it also
reduces our rate of return because the
doubling in the net worth will not come
towards our investment
so here's the formal setup for online
passing pen testing problem which is an
online version of the problem I
described and I studied we will study in
this project
suppose we have n options and they have
different values as far as n they are
all non-narrative and not known to us
at each step I we will test the eyes
option and then with the decision
the test team proceeds by choosing some
special Theta I just for the ice option
there are two chases if XI is smaller
than or equal to C I receive that the
test fails in this case we observe the
value of PSI and the remaining value in
the ice option becomes zero which we
denote by x i Prime
in this case that at PSI is higher than
z i we see that the test pauses
in this case we don't get to observe
anything
would we know that the remaining value s
i Prime is a difference between the
initial value and C to I the special we
choose
after this testing we will make a
decision on whether option I should be
accepted or rejected
such a decision is revocable meaning
that once we accept the option we don't
get to explore the remaining ones and
once we reject an option we come to a
path and to choose the option even the
remaining options are less ideal
the objective is to maximize the
remaining value in the option we choose
so we say that the algorithm is often
imperative if the following holds
on the left hand side this expectation
is always randomizing the algorithm
and this tau is the stopping time of the
algorithm that's the index of the option
we accept
so as tall climb is the remaining value
of the chosen option
on the right hand side this maximum XI
can be viewed as the store at an
omniscient profit can achieve because if
the prophet knows the values up front
it can do no testing and just pitch the
option that has the highest value so
maximum FCI is a store that the profit
will achieve
so we say that our algorithm is offered
imperative if we achieve a wall overall
for fraction of the score of the profit
this aren't fantastic problem is closely
related to this optimal starting problem
in the literature
so the setting is essentially the same
except that at step I we do no testing
we just observe the value outside
directly
and in the end we don't maximize the
remaining value because there's no
testing going on so we just maximize the
value of our chosen option
even for the simpler version of optional
stopping
we know that we have to make some
assumptions the values apps to have some
non-trivial guarantee so here's the
photo fact
for any our first smaller than n so n is
number of options
and for any algorithm
there's always a worst case instance so
that's the values X1 to x x n on which
the algorithm is not half a comparative
so this is just that the best we can
hope for is an N competitive algorithm
but that can be achieved by a fever
algorithm that selects from the N
options uniformly at random result
observing or depending on the values of
the options
so it might appear disappointing that
return to better than this random Choice
algorithm
so in the literature there are two main
problems that make some minimal
assumption on the valid acts to have
non-trivial guarantee points towards the
profiting authority the other is towards
the safety problem
for profit inequality it assumes that
the values as i's are independently
drawn from distributions D1 through the
n and let's say we know the
distributions up front we know all the
information about HDI
in this case we have to change the
notion of offer competitiveness
so on the left hand side the expectation
is now over not only the algorithm but
also the randomness in the wireless apps
and on the right hand side the Benchmark
is also expectation of its randomizing
hours
for the secondary problem
it assumes that this SI is a random
permutation that values A1 through a n
and are not known
so that's a setting where the values of
the options are arbitrary but we assume
that the options arrive in a random
random order
so here the notion of offer to Partners
is that our
uh we take the expectation both of the
algorithm and always the random
permutation acts and return p with the
maximum of AI
so motivated by these two problems in
the literature we Define two different
settings of online pen testing so the
first is towards the profit setting
where we make the assumption that the
values are independent samples from n
different distributions
and instead of saying that we know HDI
directly we have a more Journal setup
where we're given some information of
each di for example we could be given
the density function of the eye that's
the full information setting or we might
just have a few samples going from HDI
so it's a harder setting
and here important participants we have
to look at the remaining value as the
top Prime instead of an X style because
we're in the pen testing problem
similarly we Define a set review setting
where the values response to xn or
random permutation of fixed values A1 to
a n
and instead of saying that all these AIS
are unknown we have a more General setup
where we are dealing with some
information about the values and we'll
get into details of this setup later
and similarly we can change the notion
of 10 partners by replacing the value as
Tau with the remaining value as top
Prime
okay now before I get to the results
we're playing for this problem let me
describe a few related work in the
literature that models this often
starting when there's a cost for
observing each option
so starting from the word of drones in
1990 their secrets work on profit
inequalities which is the first cost for
observing each option
also there are such a few problems where
there's a cost for interviewing each
candidate or there's a discount in the
value of the of the candidates
also related is this Pandora Sports
problem of white men
in this problem we have a we still have
a lot of options and each option is
associated with a posted price so we
have to pay the price to know the value
of the option and to choose it
and there are a lot of reasonable on
this kind of reports problem as well
and finally there's a problem studied by
Albert Azar field and latent called
winner Patron and it it is in fact a
more General setup that our pen testing
problem and part of our results can also
be obtained from their results
now let's get to the results we start
with this Walmart problem when we are in
the profit setting and the item values
are ID samples
so that's a setting that we are given
some distribution D over non-native
numbers
and the option values as one so as n
such as ID samples from d
in this simple Trace can we hope for a
constant comparative algorithm
unfortunately it has a simple net result
saying that constant hypotenuse is not
possible in fact the ratio has to be log
n where n is the number of options we
have
so this proposition says this there's a
omelette and lower ground even for this
ID profit setting
and in fact this low band holds even if
we are driven distribution D we are
doing full description description of d
and also this D is not a partial
optional logical distribution
we'll see in fact choosing d as
exponential distribution will suffice
for the lower bound
so here's a simple observation
suppose we observe some option after we
test it at Social seated and the option
passes the test
then our expert menu utility in the
option is given by this conditional
exploitation of s minus Theta condition
on that as is greater than Theta
so factorially
this testing is essentially translating
the distribution of us as Point Theta
and then shifted by Theta
so we naturally asked what if there are
distributions D such that this testing
does not help
so that's the idea behind the lower
bound suppose we choose d as the
exponential distribution
and because of the memoryless property
of the astronomical distribution we know
that no matter how we choose Theta this
expectation is always one
so as a calorie the remaining value that
we achieve is at best one
on the other hand The Benchmark that we
compute with is this expecting maximum
of entropies of extential random
variable
Industrials as lot n so this is
establishes is not n gap between our
store and the benchmark
so this might be disappointing
but we'll see later that the slot n
lower bound is the only obstacle towards
being competitive
so to start with we'll see a quite
simple matching upper Bound for this ID
profit setting
for this upper bound we need this also
simple observation that suppose we
choose how alpha as the woman's Alpha
quantile of the prior distribution d
and let's say some
some option with value apps plus is a
test at special talk often then we have
this lower ground on our expected
remaining value that is half the
difference between Tau Alpha over 2 and
to Alpha
this observation can be proved simply by
a picture suppose this is a density
function of distribution D and we draw
these two thresholds Tau Alpha and top
over two
now we have these two regions
so given that as positive test after
offer we know apps forces into either
region 1 or region 2.
and by our definition of Tau both
regions will have area Alpha over 2.
so condition on that as positive test
there's a half probability that acts
falls into region 2. in which case the
remaining value
would be at least the difference between
the two terms
so as a directory we have this lower
bound on the expected remaining value
now from this observation let's get a
simple algorithm that is not n
comparative
the only field here is to paste some
random offer from this set one or number
two one before and one over powers of 2
all the way down to 2 over n
and our algorithm is really simple we
draw this random Alpha we test each
option at the same threshold of Alpha
and we will accept the first option that
passes the test
then what is our expected remaining
value
condition on the choice of offer the
observation says that our remaining
value is this amount
so over the randomizing offer we just
take the sum and divide it by log n
and by telescoping this would evaluate
to
this difference between two tiles over
order logged n
and it's not hard to see that this
difference is new this numerator is more
or less The Benchmark we compare this
that's the expected maximum SI when all
the exercise are ID samples from D so
that's a brief sketch how we match this
not n competitive ratio
foreign
our general results for the profit and
security settings
for the profit settings we can imagine a
spectrum of different settings
of different hardness depending on how
much information we have for the prior
distribution
so the easy setting would be when the
values are ID and we know the solution D
exactly
and we have already seen that there's a
matching login upper and lower bounds
a slightly harder setting is when the
diffusions are not the same but they are
still driven to us
and perhaps the hardest setting is when
the diffusions are not the same and also
we have minimal observation of each di
so instead of learning the four testing
function of d i we are just given a
single sample from HDI
and turns out that while these
different setups look
seem to have different difficulty
it turns out that the optimal compound
ratio is always logged in up to a
constant Factor
for the circuit setting we'll have two
parameters that defines these the exact
setup one of them is the Rival order of
the options the other is the amount of
information about the values that we are
given
for the arrival order
we mentioned that the typical setup is
when the permutation Is uniformly Random
but which also can see that it's harder
setting that the ordering can be
arbitrary that's when we are given some
information about A1 through a n and we
are only guaranteed that the violence as
1 to xn are these same the same M values
with some reordering
on the other structure is the amount of
information about AI we are given so in
the easy setting which requires a full
information setting we know all the
numbers A1 to a n because we also can
see the harder settings where we are
only given the maximum AI as for the
optimum information setting and the node
information setting that we are doing
nothing about AI
so we can have this table of six
different combinations of the setups and
it's not hard to see that the setting
gets harder as we go from left to right
or top to bottom in this table
in the hardest combination that the
order is arbitrary and no information is
driven that's essentially the worst case
scenario in which case and
competitiveness is optimal
but we show that apart from this hardest
combination we can always be
order and Order log n comparative and
that is also optimal up to a constant
Factor
we will Mark that for the combination of
arbitrary order and Optimum info this
log n upper bound will follow from a
upbound of our bet Azure field and later
in Star 96.
so it might appear in the slot engine
type ratio is quite robust it doesn't
depend on which profit or set rate
setting we are in but quite strikingly
for the easy sub combination of the
settings in the random order and for
information case we have a slightly
improved compound ratio of lot n over
lot n
so to reach out we Define this online
pen testing problem that models the
decision making problem on the
uncertainty
and that's a setting where the
information about the options are
released stars and to obtain this
information is costly
we show that even in this easy setup we
can't avoid the slot n lower ground
answering power ratio
but for many settings that appear harder
we can achieve this lot n up to a
constant Factor
here are some concrete open problems and
future directions so first we didn't
focus on the constant factors in this
book and to sharpen the constants would
be a natural open problem
even for the ID profit setting there's a
drop of e on the leading constant in
front of log n
we can also extend this setting of
choosing one option to select multiple
selection maybe on the top tutorial
constraints
also we can think of other models of
testing and costs so instead of getting
a binary feedback from the testing we
can imagine a smoother function as the
feedback
and also for cost functions instead of
paying a cost of theta I we can consider
a model where the cost is a general
function of the threshold Theta I we
picked for each option
thank you for listening